nady lebreton j'habite à la plaine des
grègues le jeu j'ai deux enfants je suis
âgé de 70 ans est bon je profite bien de
mes enfants et de mes petits enfants et
de mon mari et je suis actuellement à la
retraite
moi j'ai travaillé dans le service
d'aidé à domicile que nous avons mis en
place en 1982 avec mes grands chefs bien
sûr on a fait fonctionner le service
avec les différents services
le conseil général la sécurité sociale
la caf moi j'étais un peu le relais de
ces administrations
elle a été une bonne personne et qui a
beaucoup apporté beaucoup d' aide à
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de gens
je suis fier d'elle je suis contente
aujourd'hui le chemin que je ce que que
là qu'elle a menée
on est fiers d'eux ne lis que l'a fait
parce que déjà les familles pl2
d'avancer dans la vie mais mais tout
cela je dois beaucoup à mon mari et mes
enfants qui m'ont beaucoup appuyé